[Musique]
Sébastien Bavay à Québec Michel c.og à
Montréal bonsoir à vous deux
bonsoir revenons sur Tik Tok ça déboule
depuis hier on sait que l'application va
être interdite sur les appareils des
fonctionnaires et là à Québec à Ottawa
aussi là on a appris ce matin que à la
Chambre des communes à Ottawa les élus
ne pourraient plus l'utiliser sur leur
téléphone d'ici la fin de la semaine là
on apprend ça vient tout juste de tomber
Sébastien que à Québec on recommande
fortement aux élus de ne plus utiliser
l'application
est-ce que c'est
c'était une évidence que ça allait
arriver Sébastien qu'à Québec aussi on
allait suivre le pas finalement vous
avez parlé d'un effet boule de neige au
début du bulletin de Noël c'est tout à
fait ce qui se produit avec Tik Tok ça
m'étonne j'essaie de savoir pourquoi
l'Assemblée nationale ne fait que
recommander fortement aux députés de
désinstaller Tik Tok l'application sur
leur téléphone plutôt que de leur dire
purement simplement de la retirer
l'application alors que elle demande
l'Assemblée nationale à ses employés en
fait l'interdit à ses employés
dorénavant d'utiliser Tic-Toc alors la
Chambre des communes si j'ai bien
compris aujourd'hui on interdit aussi
aux députés d'utiliser Tic-Toc sur leur
téléphone ne fournit par la Chambre des
communes alors pourquoi l'Assemblée
nationale ne va pas aussi loin et ne
fait qu'une recommandation forte j'ai
pas réussi à avoir la réponse mais c'est
sûr que à partir du moment où il y a un
danger pour que des renseignements
sensibles tombent entre les mains
peut-être du gouvernement chinois c'est
sûr que tous les élus tous les
gouvernements vont agir pour empêcher
que ces informations sensibles tombent
entre les mains du gouvernement chinois
et de tout évidence enfin aujourd'hui ce
qu'on comprend c'est Tic-Toc était un
peu la porte d'entrée pour obtenir ses
renseignes Michel ça devenait une
évidence les députés devaient un peu
suivre les recommandations qu'il faisait
au fonctionnaires c'est ça
et puis écoutez à partir du moment où il
y a une application sur un téléphone
intelligent nos téléphones intelligents
aujourd'hui là sont meilleurs que les
ordinateurs qui ont qu'on avait il y a
6-7 ans alors il y a plein
d'informations qui sont sur nos sur nos
téléphones si vous êtes un fonctionnaire
si vous êtes un député si vous êtes
éliminétre vous recevez des documents
gouvernementaux probablement même des
documents au gouvernementaux que vous ne
pouvez pas partager sur votre sur votre
cellulaire un moment ou un autre si
cette application là on ne le sait pas
si c'est le fait mais la possibilité là
si cette application là transmets ça au
gouvernement chinois mettons que la
prudence élémentaire dit qu'on s'en
débarrasse alors il y a les téléphones
gouvernementaux et il y a les téléphones
privés aussi là on semble essayer de
faire une nuance entre les deux on peut
écouter le ministre cyber sécurité et du
numérique à Québec ericaire
c'est un téléphone de l'État
l'application doit être retirée pour mes
collègues ministres si c'est un
téléphone du ministère l'application
doit être retirée nous on le retire des
appareils du gouvernement parce que
souvent ça donne accès au courriel au
texto aux outils collaboratifs qui
eux-mêmes donne accès à des dossiers
gouvernementaux plus sensibles donc
c'est pour ça que là on dit non mais sur
le téléphone personnel écoutez si rien
de très sensible vous voyez de
préjudiciable il y a pas de il y a pas
de danger à l'utiliser
donc si je me souviens bien ericare n'a
pas l'application lui n'est pas un
utilisateur de Tik Tok mais il y en a
d'autres sur la scène fédérale entre
autres qui le sont des grands
utilisateurs je pense à jogg meeting on
va l'écouter puis je vais vous entendre
là-dessus comment changer stratégie
lorsqu'on est pris devant cette réalité
là où on n'est pas certain si on peut ou
pas utiliser Tik Tok écoute
je vais suivre les règlesment donc ça
veut dire qu'on doit le enlever j'ai
déjà le fait on avait de notre
cellulaire
gouvernemental et à la pause on va
apprendre une pause même sur mon
Seigneur prix privé je vais prendre un
pose pour vérifier s'il y a une façon de
utiliser la plateforme dans une manière
sécuritaire
donc je sais pas si vous êtes d'accord
Sébastien mais on sent quand même une
certaine hésitation est-ce qu'on veut se
priver de presque 900 000 abonnés dans
le cas de dog meeting l'instant
stratégique
ils sont déchirés parce que c'est aussi
quand on y réfléchi c'est une belle
façon TikTok de rejoindre une clientèle
qui regarde pas nécessairement les
pannes ou qui regardent pas des
émissions politiques ou qui lisent
peut-être pas les médias traditionnels
et qui sur Tik Tok vont chercher de
l'information alors il y en a qui vont
me dire il y a pas beaucoup
d'informations sur TikTok c'est des
recettes c'est des gens dans la vie de
tous les jours mais ça permettait quand
même aux politiciens d'atteindre puis de
façon assez humoristique parfois mais
parfois avec du contenu aussi
d'atteindre une partie des électeurs et
ceux qu'on essaie le plus d'atteindre
c'est-à-dire les gens de moins de 30 ans
les gens de moins de 30 ans alors va
falloir peut-être trouver une autre
façon de les rejoindre de les atteindre
mes Tik Tok était quand même un bon pont
intergénérationnel pour les politiques
oui Michel on avait Bruno goglyenne
Minetti à l'émission un peu plus tôt qui
disait c'est peut-être pas une bonne
idée de complètement déserter cette
plateforme là pour les policiers et
laisser le champ libre à la
désinformation donc il y a aussi ça à
mettre dans la balance
oui mais en même temps quand les partis
politiques s'en servent et on le vu on
voyait le canapé comme moi ils ont
beaucoup d'abonnés ils s'en servent
beaucoup on a vu monsieur Legault se
demander comment on devait appeler le
fromage en crotte ça s'appelle fromage
en croûte mais etc mais à ce moment-là
on encourage aussi les gens à ne pas
être prudent est-ce qu'on veut vraiment
que une compagnie chinoise est mon
bureau social par exemple et après ça
accès à peu près tous mes dossiers
gouvernementaux alors je comprends que
les participants politiques veulent s'en
servir parce que beaucoup de gens qui
utilisent ça est-ce que c'est prudent
pour eux de dire qu'ils veulent que les
gens regardent leur publicité là-dessus
quand ils savent que des documents
compromettants puis ça a pas besoin
d'être la sécurité de l'État qui est en
cause là juste un numéro de carte de
crédit ou
une clé pour avoir accès à vos fichiers
quand même numéro d'assurance sociale
peuvent être se retrouver dans les mains
d'une compagnie ou de gens qui sont
malveillants
le moment est quand même
relativement bien choisi pour
séduire contre une entreprise chinoise à
partir du moment où il y a toutes les
allégations d'un géant chinoises qui
flottent dans l'air en ce moment je
comprends que l'Union européenne a pris
à peu près la même décision à peu près
ces jours-ci que le gouvernement des
États-Unis aussi il y a comme un
mouvement international mais ça
probablement que ça sert quand même dans
la discussion politique le gouvernement
Trudeau d'agir de cette façon-là et de
sévir ou de faire de de dire qu'au
Canada on sévit contre TikTok est une
entreprise chinoise donc est-ce
que vous êtes au-delà de cette question
de précaution il y a de la politique
derrière le geste qui a été posé hier je
constate la coïncidence on va dire ça
comme ça si coïncidence il y a et je
constate la conséquence c'est-à-dire que
le gouvernement ou le Canada agit contre
une entreprise chinoise alors que depuis
quelques semaines on a l'impression que
ce sont les Chinois qui essaient de
s'ingérer dans la politique canadienne
je vous dis pas que on prend la décision
à cause de ça mais je constate que ça se
produit au moment où il en est beaucoup
question de le prétendre quand on voit
ce qui se passe effectivement en Europe
aux États-Unis c'est quand même pas les
allégations au Canada qui ont fait
bouger le continent européen là-dessus
Michel
non non tout le monde en est arrivé à la
même conclusion au même moment
d'habitude ça veut dire que quelque
chose là et
on sait qu'il y a sur beaucoup
d'applications chinoises des portes
dérobées c'est à dire une façon de
rentrer par derrière et d'obtenir des
informations alors si c'est vrai et
c'est aussi l'Union européenne le dit si
les Américains disent si on dit
probablement parce que quelque chose là
et donc encore une fois la prudence
exige que d'une part
on ne se sert plus de cette application
là quand on peut avoir des secrets dans
son téléphone et d'autre part que
n'importe qui que les gouvernements
disent à vous à moi n'importe qui de
dire écoutez il y a un danger si vous le
faites vous faites à vous risquez péril
donc on va en parler quand même de ce
moment-là du contexte en ce moment qu'on
vit au Canada de ces allégations qui
vise qui portant sur des allégations
d'ingérence dans les élections passer au
Canada et il y a de nouvelles
révélations sur l'ingérence chinoise qui
viennent encore une fois hanter le
gouvernement libéral et notamment sur la
personne choisie pour préparer un
rapport un rapport qui a été rendu
public pas à peu près une heure sur
tous les mécanismes mis en place pour
vérifier s'il y avait un gérance dans
les élections donc là il y a une
personne responsable de vérifier si les
mécanismes en place étaient adéquats
cette personne c'est Maurice Rosenberg
c'est un ancien haut fonctionnaire du
gouvernement mais il a aussi été à la
tête de la Fondation Trudeau en 2015
c'était à l'époque où la Fondation a
accepté un don de 200000 dollars d'un
milliardaire chinois c'est entre autres
le globénile qui en parlait ce matin
donc Michel qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
ce choix de la part du gouvernement
Trudeau d'avoir nommé Maurice Rosenberg
comme grand vérificateur des mécanismes
en place
c'est peut-être pas un choix qui a
posteriori se défend facilement
la bonne foi se présume là mais
la prudence encore une fois et de dire
on ne pouvait pas faire cette enquête là
sur d'éventuelles
très fier très fricotage d'élection au
Canada
en donnant les renseignements alors
comme les renseignements doivent rester
secrets il faut que la personne qui
donne le rapport soit la plus crédible
possible là il y a peut-être une
possibilité de profiter encore que la
bonne façon c'est pas clair encore une
fois donc
dans ces questions de sécurité là quand
on ne peut pas citer ces sources et
qu'on dit non il n'y a pas de problème
notre mécanisme est bon oui mais
pourquoi pourquoi vous vous basez votre
mécanisme est bon ah ça je peux pas vous
le dire ça c'est toujours embêtant pour
la crédibilité de de cette personne là
et du rapport qui est République encore
une fois si on veut avoir confiance dans
le système il faut que que tout soit
plus blanc que blanc finalement qui est
pas d'apparence aussi un film soit elle
de conflits d'intérêts Sébastien si ce
n'était que ça si ce n'était que Maurice
Rosenberg ancienne dirigeant de la
Fondation Trudeau car tu as un don d'un
homme d'affaires chinois qui selon ce
qui est publié le Global aujourd'hui ce
serait remboursé par le gouvernement
chinois
ce serait telle que tel c'est-à-dire que
ce serait une tempête à passer pour
Monsieur Trudeau bien des questions qui
se serait posées mais c'est que c'est
s'ajoute aux autres allégations de
favoritisme pour des députés ou des
candidats libéraux aux élections de 2019
aux élections de 2021 au fait que des
députés ou des candidats conservateurs
on aurait de nuit ou la Chine aura
essayé de nuire à des candidats
conservateurs dans les élections de 2019
et 2021
les ballons chinois à la rigueur aussi
qui passent au-dessus du pays bref il y
a tout un
enchevêtrement ou une suite d'événements
qui soulève un doute sur les tentatives
d'ingérence de la Chine dans les
élections canadiennes et la réponse de
Justin Trudeau de dire on prend ça très
au sérieux mais attention je vous le
répète rien ne s'est passé dans cette
élection ou qui a menacé le système
électoral canadien c'est pas rassurant
si c'est sérieux je peux comprendre que
peut-être que les Canadiens ont bel et
bien décidé du résultat final de
l'élection mais une seule tentative
d'ingérence dans une élection dans une
circonscription ne devrait-elle pas
déclencher une enquête de la part du
Premier ministre donc dans le discours
du premier ministre il y a comme pas de
la désinvolture mais il minimise l'effet
de la gérance à léguer et ça dans son
discours public peut-être que c'est un
reproche qu'on peut lui faire est-ce
qu'on va finir
l'influence chinoise par exemple dans
les universités canadiennes ils ont des
budgets importants pour amener des
étudiants chinois au Canada on a aimé ça
pendant très longtemps est-ce que c'est
encore une bonne idée de dire
est-ce que ce qu'ils font c'est juste
étudier les instituts confuciuses que
pour qui qui ont travaillé dans
plusieurs universités et plusieurs
universités ont commencé à dire ouais on
les veut plus alors il y a beaucoup on
n'est pas très sérieux au Canada quand
on parle de notre propre sécurité sur
ces choses-là on était pays du G7 on est
allié des États-Unis et leurs voisins
c'est sûr qu'il y a des gens qui vont de
façon malveillante dire mais le Canada
est peut-être le point faible là on va
essayer de s'infiltrer là-dedans alors
il faut faire très attention et là je
pense que
l'accumulation de toutes ces choses là
fait qu'on voit se poser de plus en plus
de questions à propos de notre sécurité
de comment on peut préserver nos données
et
aussi comment le procéder à la chaîne
pour le même prix et si on n'a pas
confiance dans les systèmes en place le
risque c'est peut-être qu'on émette un
climat ou qu'on soit dans un climat de
méfiance générale et que ce soit une
communauté culturelle qu'en subissent
les frais il y a aussi ça aussi dans le
risque de ce qu'on voit au cours des
derniers jours c'est dit dans le rapport
de Monsieur Rosenberg sauf erreur en le
parcours rapidement c'est un peu aussi
un message repris par Justin Trudeau il
y a ce risque là en effet en même temps
on peut se questionner sur ces fuites de
de renseignement en principe
confidentiel puis des secrets d'État qui
sont qui se retrouvent à pleine page
notamment dans le groupe en main il y a
quelqu'un quelque part qui est pas
content de la façon dont le gouvernement
gère cette situation
et veut lui mettre de la pression en
faisant fuer ou en faisant fuir c'est en
laissant aller ces informations là sur
la place publique ça aussi c'est on peut
se questionner là sur les raisons pour
lesquelles ces informations là se
retrouvent sur la place publique en
terminant Michel vous étiez avec nous
hier et je vous repose la question à
tous les deux est-ce que
ultimement juste un Trudeau va peut-être
décider bon déclenchons donc une enquête
publique parce que le meilleur nettoyant
c'est la lumière pour essayer de tourner
la page sur toutes ces allégations là je
vous écoute tous les deux en 30 secondes
oui sur l'ensemble de de ce que les
Chinois peuvent faire au Canada en
termes de renseignement en même temps le
problème de ces enquêtes-là c'est que
quand on tombe dans des documents
secrets on peut pas être publiés alors
il va toujours y avoir un doute
Sébastien et les libéraux se rappellent
la commission sur le scandale des
commandites je suis pas sûr qu'ils
veulent retourner dans ce film là avec
les conséquences que ça eut pour eux
notre chef de bureau à Québec Michel
c'est AUG chroniqueur contributeurs
réguliers à l'émission je vous remercie
beaucoup bonne soirée au revoir